council dead have been largely redacted
and we need to know that information so
we will be seeking the complete and
unredacted report again so that we can
do our proper oversight one other matter
that isn't very important to point out
and that is that as the special council
makes clear on the report the
counterintelligence findings are not
completely included in this report that
in fact they were FBI agents invented in
the special counsels team who were
looking at the issue of compromise or
counterintelligence and that some of
that information is not included others
of course it may be included but
redacted our committee the Intelligence
Committee has requested that Muller come
and testify we want to understand
exactly what was found in terms of any
counter intelligence efforts any efforts
by the Russians to make use of us
persons particularly those affiliated
with the Trump campaign as witting or
unwitting agents of the Russian
government chairman the president
tweeted out game over is is it game over
and as your opinion about articles
changed at all as a result of what you
read today well it's certainly not game
over in the sense that there's a lot
more that we need to know that's
redacted in this report and again this
report only goes to what is criminal or
not criminal other actions that may have
compromised the president or others
around him may or may not be even in
in the interest of making sure that our
policy is driven by the best interest of
the country and not by the personal or
financial interests in president or
anyone around him we need to find out
the answers to that but we will
certainly be guided by the good
investigative work that the special
counsel has done it is not our intention
to redo all the paints they can work the
Special Counsel has conducted indeed it
wouldn't be possible for us to do so a
special counsel had at his access a bevy
of FBI agents subpoenas grand juries etc
that we do not have advantage of this is
one of the reasons why it's so important
for the Congress to be able to obtain
this information so we do not have to
recreate the wheel but but it is
important to note that the facts that
are now established by this report are
damning whether they or should have
resulted in the indictment of the
President or people around him
they are damning and we should call for
better from our elected officials though
the standard cannot simply be that you
can do anything you like as long as you
can declare at the end of the day I am
NOT a crook that is not the ethical
standard the American people expect in
their present
should produce the evidence
Kilian connelly clearly hasn't read the
report because if she had she would see
that all the facts that I'm have alluded
to are not only spelled out but they're
spelled out before greater detail than I
have but look this is coming from
someone who invented alternate backs
apparently she is continuing to predict
facts
we've made two requests the Special
Counsel first we've made the request for
the counterintelligence findings and the
underlying evidence and it's very
important to understand that the Justice
Department has a statutory obligation to
provide us with counterintelligence or
foreign intelligence and so they're
required to provide that now some of
that is documentary evidence but we have
also asked for his physical testimony we
have not received a response to that yet
but the Attorney General did say during
his press conference today that he would
not oppose that and we will fully expect
them to comply with both of those
requests in terms of our look I think
he's done a deep disservice of the
country and frankly he should have never
been confirmed without committing to
recusing himself in this entire
investigation as we all know he applied
for the job by writing a 19th page legal
memo setting out why he thought an
obstruction case against the president
would not lie that it was a bogus theory
and he made good on that job application
and what he did today and what he's done
this far so I think it was a grave error
by the Senate to confirm him without
requiring his refusal in terms of beyond
that
and how would you describe your thoughts
the president did not sit well it's
certainly a disservice to the country
and to getting to the bottom of the
facts that the president was unwilling
to do what he said he would not the
first time the president has reneged on
a commitment it is one thing to ask for
written answers to questions you then
get the lawyers answers you get rudy
giuliani's answers or jessica those
answers you don't get the president
answers when you have the opportunity to
interview someone in person you have the
opportunity to fall questions and get to
the truth that was not allowed to happen
as I suspected and I and I said while
this was going on I thought it was a
mistake not to subpoena the president
but as I expected the Special Counsel
did set out his considerations and I
think foremost among them was the
president would fight it he would have
to litigate it and that would lengthen
his investigation but I think it means
the American people were deprived of
important information
we need to look at the full report
certainly what Bob Muller has revealed
on the obstruction of justice issue is
the most concerning because that of
course involves the president's own
conduct his own false it's the American
people his efforts to get other people
to tell lies his effort to deter people
who cooperating with the investigation
his effort to reward those who stuck to
the party line all of which of course
bill Barr conveniently ignored in his
press conference today all of that is
damning conduct by the President of the
United States
and I think we need some time to let
this sink in and understand the full
repercussions for the country of having
a president who lies to the country who
misleads the country urges others to do
so and frequently on a daily basis but
most significantly when it concerns an
investigation into Russian interference
in our relationship this was an attack
on American sovereignty this was an
attack on American democracy and that a
president would not only not cooperate
with it but would tell repeated
falsehoods and would not sit down and
allow a special counsel to ask questions
would in Helsinki take the Vladimir
Putin's word over his own intelligence
agencies
all of that needs to be considered by
the Congress in the country in terms of
what it means about the President of the
United States thank